[Music]
what are you doing I heard you could
punch a hole in these and make them
double-sided then you have more storage
yes but I didn't pay for a double-sided
floppy disk so so it's an ethical
dilemma you have to take a shower in a
locker next period and that's what you
worry about actually I have a bathing
suit under my pants wow that girl just
took a book on geostatistics
yeah so that's not required reading for
any science course maybe she wants to
squash the spider with it no whoa she's
reading it who is this mystery woman
should be invited to have lunch with us
I don't know so far it's just been you
and me and we know that works do you
really want to mess with the success we
could think of it as an experiment oh
you do know how to push my buttons
all right go ask her why me your lack of
testosterone makes you adorable to women
I can't argue with that
hello hello
my name is Sheldon yeah you're Sheldon
Cooper
You Know Who I am well there's only one
nine-year-old in high school and you
sell your baby teeth she knows who I am
it's going well
what do you want would you like to have
lunch with me and my friend why why else
so we can have a spirited conversation
about geostatistics you really are as
smart as everybody says my teeth are
small but my prefrontal cortex is
enormous
the addition of Libby brought a level of
sophistication to our lunchtime
discussion and her mom also packed extra
string cheese which is a well-known
social lubricant you're gonna be a
geologist that's fascinating why did you
choose that when I was a little girl
my grandparents took me to Carlsbad
Caverns and I was hooked exploring caves
that is super cool disagree dark and
closed spaces are terrifying I get
scared putting on a sweatshirt hmm
I've seen it pretty entertaining do you
know where you're going to major in in
college I'm leaning towards quantum
chromodynamics but who knows a few years
ago I would have said choo-choo trains
what about you oh geology for sure hmm
really when did you decide that a long
time ago your apple slices
[Music]